i was playing like call of duty or
league of legends where it's super
multiplayer it's super social so you
play with your friends
and i was really bad at the games
actually i was trying to figure out how
to get better at them
so the best way was to you know look up
guides or these tools that taught you
how to get better look at your own
performance compare them to other people
and that's actually how we got started
by making those tools for other games
because i knew that they helped me and
eventually i thought of
you know making games ourselves
i'm yang liu i'm a game developer at end
game interactive
we're making like real-time multiplayer
games we feel like it's an underserved
audience and one of the things that we
focus on is cross-platform
i grew up in detroit so i was there for
a few years i grew up in like detroit
elementary schools
and you know there's not you know even
till this day you know people
underestimate
places like that and it just gives you
this unique perspective that
you got to earn what you want and so i
guess
that's kind of what motivated me
[Music]
for me the american dream is just kind
of the ability to pursue
something that you're very passionate
about without like artificial
limitations that you see in other
countries or societies and here i mean
i'm an immigrant i saw the the
sacrifices that my parents made to bring
me here
and that allowed me to really pursue
what i wanted to do but i know that the
opportunity wouldn't exist
without you know being in america
we started a game company without having
pedigree right we didn't go to school
for game design
or work at a previous game company now
we're fortunate enough to have a lot of
supporters and people that believe in us
i think for a lot of other people who
wants to get into this industry
just kind of pursue it i know that's you
know overly stated
but it's possible just because of how
broad and how new
this industry is multiplayer games
they help people learn about each other
right you see
especially these days how divided
certain places are
but kids are growing up you know they
might be in michigan like me but they're
learning from people from
you know nevada they're meeting people
from new york oregon et cetera
and it teaches them that america isn't
just one little bubble state that they
live in and and
they can you know experience lots of
these different cultures even within the
same country
so i think it teaches tolerance and
acceptance and
that's what gaming really really does
you